[Music]
hi guys
i just wanted to tell you that i have
received
this beautiful award from youtube
100k and i'm super happy uh
this is the fulfillment of a dream i
think that
i have to thank you too but first and
foremost i have to thank
you guys so thank you for being around
thanks for the nice messages of
encouragement thanks for all the
warm words and compliments and very
personal
messages that you've been sending me for
a long time i started this adventure
on the 22nd of may 2008
and from that moment on i have been
receiving
an incredible amount of messages
thanking me
for making language learning happen so
to speak for showing the power
of language learning and i have to thank
you because
these positive vibes have helped me
along the years i always remember that
there is someone
behind the camera who will listen who
will watch my videos
and who maybe can benefit from
my passion and my will to share my
knowledge and you are doing the same
there are so many messages that i
received from you that were so helpful
and that's the reason why i think this
is not just my
award this is our award of all of us of
the community and i think that if an
individual learns more languages
and he's more educated he will
understand better not only his world
but also the rest of the world and a
an educated individual speaks a bunch of
languages
gives and creates a better society and
better societies can talk to each other
better and we together can literally
make the world a better place thanks
again
and um thanks to youtube thanks to each
and every one of you i'm really thankful
and let's continue
the wonderful language learning journey
you